they've got him now they've got him now
trump may have come out clean on russian
collusion
ukraine collusion the mueller probe
impeachment
two scoops of ice cream gate and all the
other scandals the democrats have tried
to gin up
but they've got him now the new york
times
is uncovered a bombshell shocking
bombshell story president trump
has a good accountant we'll break down
the non-traversial michael knowles this
the michael knowles show
[Music]
breaking new york times our accountants
are not as good as trump's accountants
that's that's the story
my favorite comment from yesterday from
travis hammer who says the left attacks
trump for not behaving like a christian
and then they attack acb for behaving
like a christian
yes yes you've caught on you see the
game here
there's nothing that any republican can
do
that will not earn them criticism other
than betray other republicans
other than become a leftist it's not
about the particular thing
that the republicans are doing for
instance donald trump
is accused of colluding with russia then
that doesn't work
he's accused of colluding with ukraine
ukraine is at war with russia
they are on opposite sides of a conflict
doesn't matter
it's okay well that one didn't work
we're going to try the other one oh okay
he's not christian enough is that is
that working
okay okay she's too christian there's no
there's no objective standard here
they're just
trying to hit them and it's not working
very well you you can't
you can't beat trump you know trump
reminds me of a biblical character some
have compared him
to uh to cyrus some have compared him to
other old testament figures i always
compare him to samson
because he derives his power from his
hair and you can too
hymns is helping guys be the best
version of themselves with
licensed medical providers and fda
approved products
to help treat hair loss we're not
talking about snake oil pills here
we're not talking about those
supplements that you see at the cash
register at the gas station
hems connects you to licensed medical
professionals online
could save you hours completely
confidential and discrete answer a few
quick questions
then a medical professional review what
you've talked about
and if they determine it's right for you
they can prescribe you medication
to treat hair loss that is shipped
directly to your door
listen i'm not a hulking athlete
i am not a necessarily the most giant
tough strong adonis of a man i always
did well with the ladies
because of my hair you can too today
hymns is giving you the best offer yet
if you're not happy with your result
after 90 days hymns will give you a full
refund right now
my listeners can get their first visit
absolutely free go to forhims.com
knowles that is for hims.com knowles uh
full refund of price paid available for
the first 90 days supply refund request
must be made between 90 to 180 days
after
product shipment is delivered
prescription products require an online
consultation with a medical professional
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate
restrictions apply see website for full
details and important safety information
that is for hims.com i think i want to
be one of those guys not just even in
the ad reads i want to be one of those
guys at the end of commercials on tv
that just like speeds through the
disclaimer at the end of that that would
be a great gig if daily wire doesn't
work out it's what i'm gonna do
that's the new trump scandal this is a
big one look at how long
this new york times article is you can
for those of you listening you can
listen to the papers
shuffle very very long long concealed
records show trump's chronic losses and
years of tax avoidance
the times obtained donald trump's tax
information extending over more than two
decades revealing struggling properties
vast write-offs an audit battle and
hundreds of millions in debt
coming due okay i'm looking through i'm
going through all the pages
gosh man there's so is so long oh my
gosh you know what word i can't find
anywhere here
illegal unlawful
breaking the law can't find any of that
here
because the new york times nowhere
alleges that president trump
broke the law or did anything wrong he
avoided paying taxes
tax avoidance is different than tax
evasion tax evasion is illegal
tax avoidance is what everybody does
when they try to deduct as much as
possible as president trump bragged
about this very thing in 2016
when he said that paying the lowest tax
rate possible
makes him smart and if he didn't do that
probably you wouldn't want him to be
your president because he wouldn't have
very good financial sense it wouldn't
have very good economic sense this
actually gets back to that youtube
comment i mentioned at the top of the
show
they attacked trump for opposite reasons
they attacked trump for enriching
himself in office
and violating the emoluments clause and
basically using the presidency as a way
to line his pockets right that's what
they've been talking about for years
whether it's by selling extra rooms at
his hotels
or whether it's by taking bribes from
russia like hunter biden
you know the thing they were accusing
him of that actually
the democrats themselves were doing so
that's what they attacked him for first
now they're saying oh actually he's
broke actually he hasn't been making any
money
actually actually he's destitute
and so when he was rich and making a lot
of money that was why he was corrupt and
we had to impeach him
and now that he's broke and he's not
making any money that's why
he's corrupt and we have to impeach him
doesn't make a whole lot of sense
of course president trump is not broke
they've tried this on him for decades
now
it shows you the the financial and
business
illiteracy of many members of the media
and the political class
which is they they don't understand how
this works so
hypothetical trump is denying that this
thing is real at all and we don't know i
mean obviously it was some corrupt
person who gave the new york times the
tax records in the first place because
they're not supposed to have access to
that
but let's say how could this
theoretically work why would trump pay a
very very low tax rate
in one year instead of another year well
we already know from the rachel maddow
show that he paid
millions and millions of dollars in
taxes with i think it was 15 years ago
he paid 38 million dollars in taxes or
something
remember that was my doppelganger rachel
maddow's big reveal on her show we have
trump's tax
records from o5 and yo he paid a ton of
money in taxes but so let's say he pays
38 million dollars in taxes one year
and then on all of his businesses takes
massive losses
the next year our tax code doesn't make
you just pay
year by year by year by year it allows
you to
write down some losses if you make them
so you don't you so you don't have to
pay money
to the government on income that you
don't have
makes perfect sense beyond that there
are a lot of people now
talking about how president trump is a
business idiot
he's broke he's you know he's uh
a total nincompoop um
it is amazing to me how many people
who have not spent the past two decades
flying around in their own private 757s
all around the world are now
accusing president trump of not having
any business acumen it's amazing to
me it's amazing to me how many people
who haven't
been regularly living the high life
penthouses in new york properties all
over the world
dating supermodels are accusing
president trump of not knowing how to
handle
his money the biden campaign is now
selling stickers that read
i paid more income taxes than donald
trump
which is not true none of the people
wearing those stickers have
in in the course of their lives paid
more income taxes than donald trump
not one of them but even if it were true
just consider this from a branding
perspective a marketing perspective this
gets to the political consequence of the
stupid attack
it's not cool to pay taxes paying
lots of taxes is not something people
brag about
they'll go hey yeah hey bro yeah how
much you paying taxes this year
oh wow you you only paid a 31
rate yeah okay bro whatever yeah i mean
i paid a 38
right but that's cool yeah not paid paid
a lot of taxes i'm a real cool guy
no uh that's not cool at all we want we
want to pay
the lowest amount that is legal and that
we can we can pay that way
this tax issue
will not change a single vote i actually
was speaking to my grandmother yesterday
and she was very nervous she goes i've
been what she watches the network news
you know channel three or whatever
channel four
and everybody is who watches that news
and only watches that news would really
believe that this is a big scandal
he said oh no trump now maybe he's going
to lose i said the scandal
scandal is not going to do anything
nobody cares about trump's taxes
nobody not one single person cares about
trump's taxes
there are many people who think that
many other people care about trump's
taxes
but nobody actually cares about it
himself
do you care about trump's taxes does
anyone you know care about trump's taxes
no completely gender but it's all they
have to attack him on
so they're going to try not going to
work same thing with amy coney barrett
amy coney barrett this
basically totally unobjectionable
judicial nominee
straight out of central casting
wonderful family brilliant
great career strong moral convictions
the ap is going after her religion we
said yesterday they weren't going to be
able to resist
going after amy coney barrett's religion
and they're doing it
this was the big tweet from the ap
breaking news breaking news scandal
controversy amy coney barra president
trump's supreme court nominee has close
ties to a charismatic christian group
that holds that men are divinely
ordained as the head of the family
and by charismatic christian group i
assume they mean the catholic church
or i don't know christianity generally
speaking
the idea that um men and women have
different roles
and that these roles are reflected in
christ in his church within the church
itself and within the family
that that is not a new kind of weird
fringy idea that
is a view held by all of christianity
that's it but beyond that they're saying
this
shocking thing amy coney barrett has a
biblical view of marriage
oh that's the big scandal
you remember how ilhan omar married her
brother do you remember that you
wouldn't remember
that if you read the ap ilhan omar
married her own
brother probably not for weird sex stuff
i think actually just to commit
immigration fraud but there is a lot of
evidence
i guess technically it's inconclusive
but there is a lot
of evidence that amy that uh that ilhan
omar married her own brother
okay the ap ignores that story because
actually as our commenter said at the
top of the show it's not about any of
these things in particular it's not even
about how they
they are going after this one group of
the catholic church because they have a
biblical view of marriage
it's just about going after the person
it's not that they care about trump's
taxes
no nobody cares about trump's taxes it's
that
they are just going after the person
it's not that they care about russian
collusion the left has been colluding
with russia and america for over 100
years it's not that they care about
ukraine collusion
joe biden and hunter biden were
colluding with ukraine
it's just about going after the guy
actually speaking of ilhan omar there is
a real scandal brewing right now that
the mainstream media don't want to cover
we'll get into that in one second first
though
got to thank our friends over at
readywise you know how much i love ready
wise now is a better time
than ever to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options ready wise
has many options such as emergency meals
freeze dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on-the-go nutrition
and new adventure meals for hiking
camping and other outdoor activities
if you do that sort of thing i'm you
know i'm not a huge outdoors guy
every once in a while i'll do that but
for me looking around
at the uncertainty in the world today
i want peace of mind i want to know that
my family is prepared
with plenty of reliable nutritional
meals
that importantly have a very long shelf
life
ready wise uses the top ingredients the
latest
food prep technology to ensure optimal
taste
and freshness then the meals are packed
into a durable long-lasting pouch
designed to keep food fresh for up to 25
years here's my view of it
go get ready-wise right now stock up
right now never been a better time
put it in your pantry hopefully you'll
never need it the way things are going
you probably will need it but
hopefully you won't just put it in there
you have peace of mind that is my plan
this week my listeners can get free
shipping at readywise.com when entering
knollskinner wlas at checkout
or by calling 855 453 2945 radiowise has
a 90 day no questions asked
return policy there's no risk whatsoever
in taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today
that is ready-wise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot
com
promo code knowles to get free shipping
fake tax scandal fake catholic scandal
with amy coney barrett
real election fraud scandal with ilhan
omar
project veritas james o'keefe strike
again
they now have on video some confirmation
of what we have been
warning about with regard to widespread
mail-in voting
from the very beginning of this
brazen democratic attempt to steal this
election
project veritas has on video an
associate of ilhan omar
allegedly bragging about having
hundreds of absentee ballots in his car
numbers don't lie number is going live
osmond just today we got 300 ballots for
jamal
there was video you can see the video
there was a video out and about
that he has the ballots in his car right
and talking about
the only way you can win is with money i
was looking at them and they were not
filled
they were blank who is the one filling
out the absentee ballots
people who work with like han omar
where do they pay the money the minute
we signed the thing
the election that's what you can pay
that's when they get paid
it's called ballot harvesting this is
something that i have been warning about
on this show for well over a year and
probably two years at this point
ballot harvesting is when you go and and
you can actually do it
in the old days when people would
request absentee ballots so even before
widespread mail-in voting where instead
of you have having to request it
the government just mails the ballots to
you it's much easier to do ballot
harvesting obviously
in that scenario but even when you had
to request the absentee ballots what
would happen
is unscrupulous political actors would
show up often to nursing homes
and then take the absentee ballots
either they
usually they would be filled out by the
senior citizens themselves at least
and then you'd take them and say okay
you're democrats okay i'm we're gonna
take those ballots and make sure they
get to the polling places and
you know maybe if if the people
harvesting the ballots
don't like your political views okay
maybe who knows if they make it to the
polling places
but we've been warning about this for a
long time
now we've got on tape multiple people
admitting to it now the reason you can't
understand some of that language is this
is
particularly prevalent it would seem in
the somali population in minneapolis
and they're tying this to ilhan omar so
how do they do it well
they do it in much the same way that all
the other ballot harvesters do it
they target older people because
for the elderly yes and it's taken away
from the elderly yes
yes there's three towers called one
tower okay and it's
all seniors and they took every ballot
every ballot they just take them from
knock on the door and say your ballots
come give it to me give it to me they
don't even pay him for it they just take
it no
and the ones that didn't vote on balance
the young people
and the women and stuff they were paying
cash cash that they were carrying bags
of money the last one
here to drive people so there's a vested
interest
but we are victims of the system they
don't
give a [ __ ] about anything two in the
morning
still hustling who is the one filling
out the absentee
ballots people who work uh with
like omar and other candidates work for
them
they came to us to our apartments they
tell us that this year they didn't go
for it
you don't go nowhere you stay home we
will telephone up so you absolutely
balance one chemist will come and get it
you just not going over you stay here
you just go nowhere you just stay here
they just take the ballots from and they
pass out sacks of cash to
the young people and the women who they
can't just take the ballots from like
they do to the elderly
we were talking about how this is
particularly true in the somali
population it feels like we're living in
a country like somalia
it feels like we're living in a country
where we can't insure
free fair elections is happening with
with all the rigor
uh that is traditional in our american
system
this is a huge this is an actual scan of
all the fake scandals that we've had to
deal with over the past several years
the russia thing the ukraine thing the
stormy daniels thing
the tax thing the this thing that thing
this is in a league of its own
one because it's real but two because it
gets to the
central issue the integrity of our
elections the left has prattled on about
how
because russia buys a hundred grand in
facebook ads
they've undermined the integrity of our
elections how about these criminals who
are going around
buying blank ballots bribing people to
vote for them
and taking them from senior citizens
what about that that seems like a crime
it is a crime and the minneapolis police
department is looking into it so
great stuff from james o'keefe and
project veritas minneapolis pd say
allegations of voter fraud are being
evaluated
the minneapolis pd is aware of the
allegations of vote harvesting we're in
the process of looking into the validity
of those statements
no further information is available at
this time on this
similar scandal brewing in new york city
new york city voters
are now receiving military malin ballots
even if they're civilians even if they
shouldn't be getting those ballots
will those ballots be counted are other
people not receiving their ballots
several people in new york city
including two journalists for the
washington post
have received quote the official
absentee military ballot
made them wonder if their their vote is
actually going to be counted beyond
sunnyside
that was in one neighborhood in
sunnyside non-service members also
received ballots in richmond hill forest
hills
and astoria
how many of these do we need to hear
before we put
a kibosh on this widespread mail-in
voting issue
people are showing up they're going out
in public if you're a conservative
you're going out in public just
generally because you're not living your
life cowering in fear in your basement
from the very scary coronavirus where
you only have a 99
plus chance of surviving if you're
a left winger if you're terrified about
the coronavirus if
if you you you don't want to show up
look around at your fellow left wingers
who go to blm rallies look around at
your
fellow left-wingers who go to antifa
rallies look around
at there are re to go to ruth bader
ginsburg's funeral who go to george
floyd's funeral who go to all of these
events
where when it's politically convenient
the left says oh people can gather in
large groups it doesn't matter
if you can do that if you can go to
george floyd's funeral if you can go to
ruth ginsberg's funeral
if you can go to a blm rally if you can
go to an antifa rally if you can go to
any of these things
you can go vote in person and if you
won't vote in person
without outside of very narrow
exceptions
military infirm people who need absentee
ballots
outside of those exceptions if you if
you won't show up to vote
don't vote don't vote you don't want to
vote
fine don't vote but don't allow
criminals and election stealers to go
vote on your behalf
beyond that scandal that's a pretty big
one but the second biggest one
of 2020 the democratic candidate for
president
is barely conscious and we're going to
see that on display tonight at the
debate
it's going to be the big debate donald
trump and joe biden
joe biden on msnbc very friendly tv
station just a few days ago
he's chatting with the anchor there and
he's making a strong point about what a
terrible
trump has done on a certain aspect of
legislation except he can't remember the
name of the legislation and
very sadly the anchor has to just give
him the answer at the end
for example the paycheck protection act
you know one percent of the money's gone
out
one percent one percent of the uh
that's not the paycheck the the the um
uh
the uh the bill for a small for major
for small business
may steve lenny one percent's gone out
why isn't that lady running for
president that lady obviously has a much
clearer grasp on the policy issues than
joe biden does
he doesn't even he's invading against
this one
law and then turns out oh wait a second
he's actually thinking about the other
law
very sad very pathetic i know we don't
want to set expectations too low for the
debate tonight but the expectations
already set low joe biden set them
so what's going to happen i i still
think there's a chance that they find
some way
to to game the system tonight donald
trump has called for joe biden
to take a drug test before he goes out
there on the stage tonight
that's probably not a serious suggestion
he just wants to set it in people's
minds that joe biden is taking
performance-enhancing drugs which
i wouldn't be surprised if he is and
that's kind of trump's mo
is to is just set these insinuations so
people can see it even if he doesn't get
the uh the concession that he's looking
for
that is going to go on tonight i've got
a big warning
though for president trump beyond the
setting expectations low i have a
warning for president trump that
i haven't heard people give him before
which we'll get to in one second but
first
you know before a big debate like that
you need a good night's sleep and the
best way to get a good night's sleep is
my pillow
that's what i think i love my pillow i
love the my pillow sheets i love the my
pillow mattress topper
most of all i love the my pillow pillow
which is my favorite pillow i've ever
owned
you all know michael lindell he's a
great conservative he's a great
christian he comes out
and is very open about his political
views and about his faith well he's the
inventor of my pillow
mike's latest deal is on the giza dreams
sheets
which are made from the world's best
cotton giza
they are extremely soft and breathable
they are extremely durable
right now the giza dreams sheet is
available at a low
price one low price plus free shipping
with promo code daily wire
all of the my pillow products come with
a 60 day money back guarantee
you you won't need it i'm promising you
this right now i don't want to promise
but i'm actually i'm willing to with my
pillow
you're not going to want to return it
you're not i'm telling you these
products are so i've always liked mike
lindell so i would use my pillow anyway
just because of that then i tried the
products they are the best they're such
high quality
all my pillow price they get the 60 day
money back guarantee you're not gonna
want it
you're gonna want to keep the product go
to mypillow.com click on the radio
listener square to check out
the two for one low price on the giza
dream sheets plus free shipping
there are also very deep discounts on
all other my pillow products two
enter promo code daily wire or call
800-651-1148 for these great
radio and podcast specials i've got
some advice for president trump tonight
here's the big warning
not about don't be too mean to joe sure
don't be too mean to joe
not about don't set expectations too low
they're already kind of set
but yeah you always want to keep
expectations a little higher here's my
big warning for trump
don't take this lightly don't think this
is a slam dunk because of one reason
joe biden for all of his other
faults and flops and doofy statements
and
cognitive decline joe biden is an
effortless liar
that is his political superpower i'm not
saying he's even a malicious law i think
he's a cynical liar
he doesn't care about the truth he can
lie
on a dime he can change his position on
a diamond
he might not even know that he's done it
he this is a
the kind of typical vice of politicians
they don't believe what they say they
can say anything they talk about both
sides of their mouth
well joe biden is a top politician this
guy's been in in office
for about 20 i think it is of our
country's history
he's been in he's been in political life
he gets he got elected 50 years ago okay
and during that time
he has shifted positions a lot i'll give
you just one example the supreme
court issue filling the seat during an
election year
now that president trump has nominated
judge barrett now that it looks like
she's going to be confirmed
joe biden is furious he's calling this
an abuse of power
violating the essence of what the
founders thought that the voters should
have a chance
to make it have a say the election has
already begun
this is an abuse of power of what
they're doing and i think we should
focus on
what this is going to mean for health
care
what it's going to mean for once again
being able to say
if you're pregnant it's a pre-existing
condition be able to charge women more
for the same procedure as men
it's wrong it's an abuse of power it's
wrong it's an abusive better than any
pivots into the health care thing
because the democrats
believe that that's the only way that
they can try to sell their opposition to
judge barrett's nomination
but that's what he says he's put this
person up in an election year
come on the election's already on it's
an election year that's wrong it's an
abuse of power
just a few years ago though joe biden
said the absolute opposite he said it
wasn't an abuse of power
when barack obama put up a judicial
nominee in an election year
actually it was their the constitutional
responsibility of the president and of
the senate
there is no bite rule it doesn't exist
there's only one rule i
ever followed on the judiciary committee
that was the constitution clear rule
of advice and consent
and advice and consent includes
consulting
and voting
nobody is suggesting individual senators
have to vote yes
on any particular presidential nominee
voting no
is always an option and it is their
option
but say nothing see nothing
reading nothing hearing nothing
and deciding in advance simply to turn
your back
before the president even names a
nominee
is not an option the constitution
leaves open it's a plain abdication
of the senate's solemn constitutional
duty
it's amazing how joe
can become so impassioned so
earnest while giving completely
contradictory points of view
just a few years apart so in case your
head is spinning right now
it is an abuse of power for trump to
nominate
and for the senate to confirm a judicial
nominee in an election year
three four years ago it was the senate
and the president's solemn duty to
nominate and confirm
uh or at least nominate and vote on a
judicial nominee during an election year
it was a requirement of the constitution
and then it gets even better because he
had flipped it one other time you heard
him reference the biden rule
in that speech the biden rule refers to
a
rule that joe biden articulated back in
1992
during george h.w bush administration
when there was a chance
that you could see a judge nominated
during an election year
and biden said absolutely it would be
wrong
it is my view that if a supreme court
justice resigns tomorrow or within the
next several weeks
or resigns at the end of the summer
president bush should consider following
the practice of a majority of his
predecessors and not and
not name a nominee until after
the november election is completed the
senate too mr president
must consider how it would respond to a
supreme court vacancy
that would occur in the full throes of
an election year
it is my view that if the president goes
the way of presidents
fillmore and johnson and presses an
election year nomination
the senate judiciary committee should
seriously consider
not scheduling confirmation hearings on
the nomination
until ever until after the political
campaign season is over well wait a
second i thought that it was the
solemn duty of the senate to vote i
thought that that was
joe biden's deeply held belief was that
the senate had to vote
on the judicial nominees and that's what
the constitution required
so just to catch you up 1992 under a
republican
administration uh joe biden says
that uh president shouldn't nominate a
judge senate shouldn't confirm then you
get to 2016
republican administration the president
should nominate a judge
and the senate should confirm or at
least vote and then now
2020 it's an abuse of power the
president should not nominate a judge
and the senate should not vote
i mention all of that not to point out
that joe biden's a hypocrite
obviously that is true the only
explanation i can see is that he doesn't
write his own speeches
which we know is also true because he
had to drop out of the 1988 presidential
race
for plagiarizing other people's speeches
i only
mentioned this because you saw the
passion you saw the earnestness you saw
the effortlessness
of his flip-flopping of his hypocrisy of
his lying
of his just i guess sophistry is the
right word for it
he's he's the content of what he's
saying doesn't matter the content the
substance
can change all joe biden is is the
performance
is the is the pathos is the the emotion
is this appeal i mean this is joe biden
hasn't believed a thing in his whole
life joe biden
is just there to slap you on the back
and make you feel good that's why i
never thought the hair sniffing and the
back massages
were all that creepy i mean they look a
little bit creepy on tv but it's not
about him being a sexual weirdo i don't
think
it's about him being this ingratiating
simpering flattering politician
who isn't trying to sell you on any
ideas he's just trying to make you like
him personally
and get your vote that way trump's got
to watch out for that
because i don't think that goes away
with cognitive decline if anything
is sort of more sympathetic now even
conservatives are saying gosh this is
elder abuse what they're doing to this
guy
you've got to watch out for that
masterful emotional
manipulation tonight's the night are you
ready for it at 9 pm eastern 6 pm
pacific
donald trump joe biden are going to face
off all these questions will joe biden
fall asleep
will donald trump wear a mask hope not
join us for an all-new episode of daily
wire
backstage to watch the debate with us
get our immediate live reaction to this
major political event even better
join the daily wire now as an insider or
all access member your 20
off with code debate d-e-b-a-t-e so you
can watch all the debate coverage live
on our apple tv or roku app this is a
once-in-a-lifetime election now you're
probably you're going to get other
elections but not like this one
uh you are going to want to get the full
experience you also by the way when you
sign up get not just one
but two leftist years tumblr so head on
over to dailyr.com
you will get 20 off your daily wire
membership with code debate when you
sign up today we'll be right back with a
lot more
joe biden spent the last three or four
weeks accusing donald trump of hating
our troops
spent the past three or four weeks he
made these slick campaign commercials
that came out within about 12 hours or
so of that atlantic
hit piece based on four anonymous
sources confirmed by fox news
with an anonymous source so therefore
not confirmed in any way
disputed by 25 26 officials who went
on the record to defend the president
against this calumny
but the thought was that the story was
that donald trump called the troops
losers idiots
fallen soldiers were just dummies who
gave their lives for nothing
joe biden harped on this demagogue this
now it turns out
we have it on video that joe biden
called our troops
stupid bastards in 2016. and two
i agreed johnson to the academy
[Music]
must be slow here man it's kind of hard
to hear exactly what he's saying in the
audio of that clip
you can hear a little bit more clearly
in a video that was taken by one of the
one of the soldiers in the audience it's
pretty clear though he calls them stupid
bastards
one i married jill and two
i appointed johnson to the academy i
just want you to know that
it's clap for that you stupid basket
clapped over that clap for that so
he his campaign is now saying that it
was a joke and some of the troops were
laughing and cheering
so it's no big deal nothing to see here
my point is not over
what joe biden says to the troops or not
my point is over the double standard my
point is over the insincerity my point
is over the hypocrisy
they completely invent quotes from
donald trump
calling the troops idiots and suckers
completely invented
no evidence he ever said that whatsoever
that's the biggest scandal
of all time joe biden makes campaign
commercials about it then we
actually get video of joe biden calling
them stupid bastards
no big deal no big deal nothing to see
here
this is why all of these non-traverses
the tax thing with trump or whatever you
know the amy coney barrett's religion
this is why they are going this is why
they're not going to have any effect
the democrats have cried wolf one
too many times so even if there were a
scandal that cropped
up i don't know that anyone would care
there have there hasn't been i mean now
it's just completely
nonsense but even if a real scandal were
to crop up about a republican i don't
think
people would care that much because we
couldn't believe it because the people
who are making the accusations
have no credibility at all they've
squandered that credibility
by both inventing claims and by
their abject hypocrisy and double
standards
and well joe biden is extremely oily
he's an oily anxious politician the one
thing
to remember here is and this is also
some advice for president trump tonight
joe biden doesn't lead on anything he's
not a leader he's just a guy who blows
in the wind right he's in completely
empty suit he licks his index finger he
puts it up in the air
and he checks to see which way the wind
is blowing and so if you can lead on an
issue
you can get a real advantage over him
it's why this guy has been running for
president
since 1988 and has never managed to win
it's because he he doesn't lead no one
wants to follow that guy he's always an
okay number two or number three but no
one actually wants to
follow him this has not been clearer
this entire race than on the issue of
supreme court packing you know the
democrats are threatening to pack the
supreme court top democrats are saying
that they ought to do that add more
justices to the court as a way to get
back at republicans who are going to
confirm a judge
which is absolutely their constitutional
right to do and responsibility to do
so joe biden's asked a question on court
packing and he gives
the most transparently cynical and
political answer
i have heard from him in at least
several days so i asked biden a
hypothetical question
if he's elected president and democrats
gain control of the senate
would he consider adding more seats to
the supreme court
it's a legitimate question but let me
tell you i'm not going to answer that
question because
it will shift all the focus that's what
he wants he never wants to talk about
the issue at hand he always tries to
change the subject
but let's say i answered that question
then the whole debate is going to be
well widened setter didn't say biden
said he would or wouldn't
hey mr biden will you answer my question
no no i'm not going to answer your
question because trump never wants to
answer the question
what yeah trump always wants to shift
the debate let's talk about trump
uh tru no i don't i don't think it's
trump who's avoiding the question and
shifting the debate i think it
it would be you because i asked you a
very clear question and biden admits
that it's a clear question
biden admits it's a legitimate question
he says yes no it's a legitimate
question
but i don't want to give an answer you
see because that would be politically
disadvantageous to me
because i know that the radicals in my
party the radical base
wants to pack the court but i know that
most normal people
don't want to pack the court and so i'm
just not going to give you an answer
because trump avoids questions
no i think you do although he he does
have a fairly decent political gut joe
biden because he realizes
most voters i don't know about most
democrats but most voters do not want to
pack the court
we've got a poll out this was conducted
by mclaughlin and associates from
september 23rd to 27th
among a thousand registered likely
voters
62 percent want to keep nine justices on
the supreme court they actually support
an amendment to the constitution to set
the number of judges
at nine supreme court justices as
opposed to
18 of people who do not favor the
amendment so it's not even saying do you
prefer nine justices or not
it's actually going further than that
saying do you want a constitutional
amendment to set it at nine justices
and a clear majority of americans a
whopping 62 percent
say yes and only 18 percent say they do
not
want the amendment so it is a total
loser issue for them
and they should not they should not
go into it if they care about their own
political skin
but they might not be able to resist it
ed markey senator ed markey
says if republicans confirm barrett then
we should end the filibuster
and expand the court and i'm sure this
raises him some money and gives him a
little credit with his base
but it's going to hurt them in the long
run so democrats with cooler heads with
a little bit of a longer view
who have a little little uh deeper sense
of their own
of their own political survival guys
like dick durbin second most powerful
democrat in the senate
senate minority whip he's coming out
there and saying whoa whoa slow down
guys
so he comes out he was talking to george
stephanopoulos he said hey i disagree
with hillary clinton on this whole
don't concede the election thing i'm not
trying to steal the election no
let's respect constitutional order shut
up democrats
i know we're going to try to steal it
but don't say it out loud
shut up so he's doing this again on the
on the
court packing issue he's doing this
again
specifically on amy coney barrett he's
not saying that if the
if the democrats or if the republicans
confirm barrett we're going to pack the
court
we're going to what are you saying is
yeah
the amy coney bear thing is really
unfortunate
but we can't do anything about it we
could slow it down
perhaps a matter of hours maybe days at
the most
but we can't stop the outcome what we
should do is to address this now
respectfully but understand the context
george
we have to slow it down we can't do
anything though to stop it
now that's not true it's not but it's
interesting that he said it
but it's not true they they could they
could mount a good
case to stop the barrett nomination they
could
rip up her past rip up her family rip up
her religion
find something something anything to
ruin this
woman's life over if they can't they can
just make it up like they did to brett
kavanaugh
right they launched a very strong attack
on brett kavanaugh
and they nearly derailed his nomination
they didn't succeed in the end but
they came pretty close so why is dick
durbin saying there's nothing they can
do of course there is
murkowski and collins two squishy
republicans
they they have said that they won't go
along with the nomination in an election
year
so now you're down to what 51 votes four
and
49 against so you probably pry a couple
more away but dick durbin
is trying to do here is dissuade
democrats
from launching those very attacks
because he knows they won't play well
dick durbin knows things like court
packing don't play well but more than
that he knows things like
attacking this nice woman's family are
going to kill the democrats
he knows things like attacking this
woman's religion are going to kill the
democrats in november
if they if democrats just start
launching all-out attacks on
christianity you think that's going to
play well in the battleground states
that they have to win
think that's going to play in
pennsylvania i don't think so buster
and so he's he's lying to them he's
saying no there's nothing we can do
please stop please don't launch
please don't do this to me democrats and
he's doing it
to discourage what could be effective
attacks at stopping the barrett
nomination but ultimately will be pure
victories even if they won
ultimately would be self-defeating at
the ballot box
in november this is
because dick durbin also has a good
political gut and he sees which way
things are blowing democrats would be
would be wise to make this kind of pivot
on another issue too not just on the
religion not just on the family not just
on the court
on another issue that's very divisive
black lives matter this whole craziness
of defund the police
four out of five black voters say they
don't want to defund the police and yet
democrats allegedly speaking on behalf
of black people
say they do want to defund the police
cooler heads are beginning to prevail
cooler heads
are beginning to recognize gosh all of
these narratives we've been told by the
democrats who've been crying wolf
for at least the last four years
continuously
and actually for much longer than that
gosh these narratives
they don't seem all that true of all
things we'll turn to the sports world
charles barkley
was talking to shaquille o'neal they
were talking about
the brianna taylor case say her name
this is one of the central cases
of the blm movement which was which was
presented to us as this innocent woman
who was sleeping in her bed and racist
cops came in kicked down the door and
executed her because they're racist and
racist or something like that
the reality not quite true brianna
taylor tied in with a pretty significant
drug trafficking ring
uh the boyfriend that she was with at
the time was shooting at the cops the
cops shooting back it was a totally
legal warrant right completely different
narrative
so i don't i don't i don't think that i
turned to the sports world for
conservative political commentary okay
i don't think i i turn to it for even
all that moderate political commentary
but
charles barkley's giving this talk on
black lives matter he says you know
we shouldn't lump in all of these cases
together this brianna taylor one seems
seems
a little bit different it's bad the
young lady lost her life
but you know we do have to take into
account that
her boyfriend did shoot at the cops and
shot a cop
so like i say even though i'm really
sorry she lost her life
i don't think that we can just say we
can put this in the same situation with
george floyd and our
ahmad aubry i just don't believe that
yeah i think we do have to
mention uh that this guy shot at the
cops right and shaquille o'neal i
couldn't we couldn't actually find the
clip because i don't watch this show
because i don't like watching a lot of
sports
shaq agreed he said i have to agree with
charles this one is sort of lumped in
you have to get a warrant signed in some
states do allow no knock warrants and
everyone was asking for murder charges
when you talk about murder you have to
show intent
a homicide occurred and we're sorry a
homicide occurred when you have a
warrant signed by the judge you're doing
your job and i would imagine
that you would fire back of course any
reasonable person doesn't matter what
political party you're affiliated with
not that many reasonable people these
days would call themselves democrats but
it doesn't really matter if you consider
yourself on the left or in the center or
on the right if you're a reasonable
person you probably have that point of
view
oh yeah some of these cases maybe don't
look great but but some
some just don't don't deserve to be
lumped in because
it's so much clearer and i think
democrats are the smart democrats like
dick durbin are beginning to see that
they're saying whoa
guys pump the brakes pump the brakes
we're heading into november and
we've got all these electoral advantages
and we're trying to steal the election
through mailland but
you guys are giving it all away why
because they keep
crying wolf and when you do that time
and time and time again when your hair
is always
on fire when you're always running
around screaming eventually people
tune you out crying wolf speaking of the
animal kingdom i do have to give a quick
shout out
to a hero animal reporters for cbs news
and other mainstream media outlets uh
were sent running
on monday monday morning after an
aggressive raccoon
began attacking them outside of the
white house
i don't have the raccoon's name anywhere
but he is a hero i support him i salute
you mr raccoon i put you up
in the pantheon of great animals up
there with harambe and cecil the lion
uh please if you want to suggest a name
for this raccoon please do it in the
comment section below but i i
you know i always want to call out
moments of heroism
and just great accomplishment in in
american politics and a a white house
raccoon chasing away mainstream media
supporters
certainly fits the bill crying
crying wolf and chasing being chased by
raccoons that's what the democrats are
doing
i can't wait for the debate tonight you
can join us on the backstage it'll be a
lot of fun if you don't miss or if you
don't catch the backstage rather
you can tune in tomorrow and we will
break down the highlights for you i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
if you prefer facts over feelings aren't
offended by the brutal truth and you can
still laugh at the insanity filling our
national news cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there